in the early days you were a bouncer
nightclub now you are on Dancing with
the Stars most amazing thing in the
world because I told them fools are cake
dance and can't dance and they still
won't me
icon if you know they want you told a
mag I see our cake days they still want
me the show is gone dick how stupid is
dead hey wait so you're on Dancing with
the Stars you accept it and you're angry
about it well always well accepted
accepted me see this thing gonna like
this my shoes are you I came from
practice to be with you coz I love you
re I've decided to do the show because I
wanted to get the money to the kids at
st. Jude and Shriners Hospital wait
you're doing this yes yes yes so so so
I'm doing it for the kids even though
our K days I tell them to try that's
what it's all about you know country
Iran and and and you you know any dance
moves from your bouncer days did you
used to get out there on the dance floor
and I'm glad just brought it up : e be
able to see a bounce love dancing he
ain't doing his job right yes that club
is in trouble
dancer so yeah I never danced when I was
not being a bouncer or bodyguard are you
I was third like the seal yeah okay you
never bust the move did you uh do you do
you think you have a good chance on
dance with the Stars I'm glad you
brought it up Conan you know it's on the
card I know that's right that's right
they already has a misty who your
toughest competitor me who so you think
you're gonna win dance with the Stars no
no no it's not about winning already won
before I got on a dance floor because
I'm giving the money to the kids so I
already won hey that's a great attitude
you're the only person I know who says
I'm giving all the money away for
charity and then gets mad I will say
this I will say this you're one of the
nicest people don't tell him body I'm
he's one of the truly nicest people I've
met in show business
he is constantly and when I out with you
people go crazy they come running and he
spends all of his time talking to kids
grown-ups taking pictures with everybody
he's an extraordinary guy he really is
either you're a good man in this you
said if you win Dancing with the Stars
you're gonna shave off your yeah well my
mohawk to stand in solidarity with the
kids who fighting cancer amazing I'm
credible all right well Dancing with the
Stars airs Monday nights at 8:00 on ABC
he's mr. t what can you say we'll be
right back
[Applause]
you